what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at tiff 2022 for an
interview with the team behind alice
darling huge congratulations on your
movie it is mighty powerful thank you so
much thank you i mean it i mean it mary
i'm coming your way first i apologize in
advance because you're going to do this
a million times today but just in case
anyone out there does not know what this
movie is about can you give us a brief
description absolutely so alice darling
is a film about a woman who seems to
have a very ordered polished life she
has great friends she has a job she has
a handsome artist boyfriend um but when
her friends invite her away for a week
to cottage country they suddenly start
to see that she's behaving quite
strangely and she's under huge strain
and they begin to understand that she's
in an emotionally abusive relationship
and it's about how they respond and what
happens when her boyfriend turns up at
the cottage all right so digging into
the process of getting this off the
ground i was reading that uh katie and
lindsay really wanted to work with you
for a while and then this project came
along and it finally got the green light
you finally moved forward with one so
what was it about this script and this
timing that made it right for you yes
that's right katie and lindsey and i
have been wanting to work together for a
while and when they sent me the script i
think i just
i remember that i read a quote years ago
and sam taylor wood the director said i
was that joe wright who's another
british director said to her that you
should direct the movies that you feel
you know a secret about or the scripts
that you feel you know a secret about
and i suppose there's many ways of
interpreting that but when i read the
script alice darling i felt like
i knew i could do something quite
interesting with it i felt like i could
draw out her psychology in quite an
interesting way it's sometimes it's
quite difficult to dramatize what's
happening inside people and a lot of
what happens to alice in the film is
very internal and i was really
interested how do you draw that out with
sound with image and how do you work
with someone on the performance of that
and so that's what made me want to do it
i'm not going to forget that idea about
a secret i really like that um
and i apologize for this question now
because i feel like i'm asking you for
the secret sauce right away but what
what is the key to convey or actually
what's the key to knowing that you are
conveying someone's internal struggle
while you're on set but also maintaining
that beautiful subtlety that you managed
to achieve in this film oh my gosh
acting um
oh yeah well this
these questions are always so hard
because you're like well if i could put
it into words that's why i apologized
first i mean you know um
uh look i think the
this film was especially interesting um
going into it because um
you know for various reasons
not not limited to the pandemic um i i'd
been kind of just working like project
after project kind of without stopping
and um and then i you know the pandemic
many things happened and um it was the
first time that i was going to be on set
again and and i realized like i'd kind
of gotten into this pattern of um
kind of knowing how to act for video
village and for the dailies and like
there are
uh
sort of
tools in my bag of tricks that i can
always reach for to make sure that i
know everyone at video village is gonna
go like i think we got it
and um
and that becomes a little soul-crushing
eventually and um
and it was um
such a
internal performance as you say like it
was um
uh really challenging to trust that even
if
the dailies weren't sparkling it would
be a whole performance like that we were
building a whole movie over time which
you're always doing but it's very
tempting to give in to that immediate
pleasing thing of like what do they
think it what do they think at the
monitor like mommy am i good enough um
and it is difficult to trust that like i
know it feels like right now the last
couple of days the couple of scenes that
we've shot like nothing's really been
happening but it will build to something
because i know that
um what's happening inside me is the
truth
and um
that is a a really difficult thing to um
trust when you know like
there's a couple of little things i
could do that i know that i've done
before that would make everybody go like
oh okay it's really coming through and
um i think part of it was like the scope
of the film gave us the
um ability to
um like rely on each other and trust
that we were all on the same page
because it was such an intimate film
i have so many follow-up questions my
head is exploding right now this is a
this is another meet you
wow it's really hard to talk about
acting and anna just did it really
really really well so this is another
really big question but you talking
about how kind of like the tools that
you use have evolved over the years is
making me think of this what would you
say is the biggest difference between
your priorities when picking projects
when you first started out compared to
what you want now in terms of the
stories you're telling or the type of
onset environment you want to work in i
mean i feel like the answer to that
question is within the question you know
it's obviously when you first start out
i was just so
bold over and grateful that anyone would
hire me you know you are trying to keep
the lights on at a certain point in your
career and um
like i think that there's when you're in
that
state for so long of like
can i pay my rent and does anybody want
to work with me um you can it can be
several years before you catch up to the
idea that like that's not really the
issue anymore anna you know you're
allowed to like take a break and take
stock and um
yeah i think that
uh
i was just sort of
on
like a very exciting and in many ways
fulfilling treadmill but it was still
like i just wasn't really i was just
sort of putting one foot in front of the
other
and um
you know various circumstances kind of
led me to taking this break and um you
know i i remember watching um the
assistant and this film swallow and
feeling like that was
you know something so
um
interesting and like it had that
gravitational pull where you really lean
in when you're watching those movies and
um
and then you know when i got this script
i just thought it was an amazing
opportunity to try something uh
different and sort of scary
not enough people talk about how good
swallow is yeah i am obsessed with that
movie and haley bennett's performance in
it um kennedy oh so with um with this
movie it is largely focused on alice's
evolution and how the friends are
supporting her through it but tess
experiences a pretty significant amount
of growth as well i don't want to spoil
anything here but just to tease what she
goes through can you maybe isolate what
you think her greatest asset is as a
friend but then also what is her
greatest weakness that she has to
overcome so she could use that asset to
help alice dang
i think her greatest asset is loyalty
extreme loyalty
um
and you know i think
not just as
as tess in the film but also as gunny
dio the actress a lot of it was just
sort of trying to be there and support
alice or anna in the moment you know um
and what was the second part of the
question
what is her greatest weakness that she
needs to be able to overcome in order to
make the most of that asset her
stubbornness i think i would say i think
it would be her stubbornness yeah
um but i think the loyalty and the
stubbornness kind of like coincide and
like are married together you know um
but yeah that's why there's no clear
answer to that yeah exactly
um charlie for you i know you did a good
deal of research before jumping into
this project can you isolate something
that you found in that research that
maybe we don't usually see on screen in
a role like this that you wanted to make
sure shine through more than anything
well it's interesting when you ask about
research i mean i tried like a good
little actor to do as much as i could
but
the research i needed was
what people who have perpetrated this
kind of abuse
have to say about it
and it's obviously very difficult for
people to analyze their bad behavior
because there's so much shame attached
to it i think this movie is like kind of
drenched in shame right he's so
ashamed and now that's infected all
these other people's lives
so it's actually really hard to find
um
work that delves into to these people's
shame and why they behave that way
there was a canadian documentary a
couple years ago called a better man
which was about a woman who had been in
an abusive relationship
a physically abusive relationship when
she was much younger and she met up with
the perpetrator of that violence 20
years later to try to get him to talk
about it and i thought oh this is
exactly what i want and even after he
had agreed to do it she would take him
right up to the point where he
tried to explain these urges and this
awful behavior and he just couldn't
confront it so i really think there is a
dearth of
of work done on that and that's
difficult because the only way that
you're going to change people's behavior
is to take them right up to the point
where
they're flooded with shame and then try
to make them make different decisions i
can't even imagine going into that
headspace and exploring all that um
on the bright side here with your scene
partners it just seems like you you are
like an a plus group with like peak
level chemistry the entire time we don't
have one me here and i'm also like
mighty obsessed with her and her work
she is a ray of light for the three of
you in particular can you
this is a big question again can you
each tell me something about the other
that you really appreciate as a scene
partner where you wouldn't have been
able to access something in your own
character if it wasn't for how they
helped you on set including her well
i mean we were literally just joking
about this that i would be like fully
just staring at ghanidio in between
takes and going like i'm like obsessed
with you
like of course you are like she just i
fully and it all like and i haven't seen
that and i haven't seen you in like
since we made the movie
and then like we're over there and i'm
just like yeah it's all i'm fully
obsessed with this girl and i do think
that like she does have um a very kind
of tess like
there is like a weird it's like a regal
stubborn
like it's it's um it's a presence and um
and i think like what was really
powerful you know we were again just
talking about this scene where she just
brings me a sandwich
and
because her character is so stubborn
just that much vulnerability just to
bring me a sandwich is such a leap and
it was so powerful in that moment like
that
it's um when two people are avoiding
each other and kind of in denial about
what's happening you know but you can
just share like okay well we'll eat half
a grilled cheese sandwich together and
that will be enough for now that was
like such a beautiful talk we don't have
to talk but but i'm here you know so sh
like her bringing that little ounce of
vulnerability was like very very
powerful because as uh as a performer
and as a person she's incredibly strong
so to see that was
was great did you guys get that on
camera i don't i don't
honestly
for me i just wanted to i just like i
said before i just really knew what my
role was
as the actress and as tess and it was
the same and i was all to support my
friend to support anna to support alice
to support anna in the scenes to be
there to give her whatever you needed
you know and then
as uh as tess that that's really
basically the same thing that she was
doing she you know but again was kind of
blocked by her stubbornness and
everything um
but yeah and then like working with me
was like
amazing she's
so bloody amazing she was just we it was
funny because it almost felt like it was
like me and her and then you and then
like it would have the like because
we would have these sort of like this
is she okay
and then you know like i don't know it
was like a sep it was
it was us trying to collectively care
for this other person and collectively
be there again as actresses for this
person who's doing a really amazing job
at such a difficult crazy layered role
you know you killed her obsessed with me
oh my god why are you obsessing okay
stop cut
[Laughter]
i don't want to spoil anything but i do
want to ask you about like the shot
composition and the blocking of the
scene that you chose for the still for
this film because before i even read the
description there is something about
that frame that is incredibly striking
and immediately pulled me in and had me
circle the film and say i need to cover
this so can you with me without maybe
spoiling anything can you talk a little
bit about that particular uh blocking
strategy to make that kind of impact
with an image like that that's a that's
a big scene and as you say it's to say
much about it will reveal a lot but i
have to say that the blocking was a
choice that animate which was it's it's
quite difficult to say this without
talking about what the scene's about but
effectively she wanted to be accessible
to uh wummy so who plays sophie so she
was turning her back
um on charlie playing simon and um they
then playing two woomy so that became a
very strong duo there and then i asked
ganodio to come around and act as kind
of the bodyguard and so she's facing off
kind of protecting
alice in that direction so that's why
the three of them are in that position
uh in that moment it's just like a
beautiful scene i can't wait for i love
the idea of everyone's first exposure to
the movie being that frame and then
experiencing the story and realizing
what that frame means so it is something
else i want to come back to you now
something i was reading in the press
notes really kind of caught my eye the
idea of you being open to doing scenes
two extremely different ways where
either it's like more heightened and
frightening or something a little more
subtle so is there any particular scene
that you went into and thought one way
was going to be right but then by
experimenting with the other way you
figured out that was the better route to
take
one thing that i was really
uncomfortable with from the start
that i spoke to mary a lot about was the
idea that somebody who behaves like this
has like they obviously have a bad side
and a good side but the idea that all
the good stuff in his behavior is a lie
and it's just like a front for his real
bad self it was important to me that all
of those things were true of him right
somebody who's prone to
tantrums and rage and
desperately controlling behavior
is
a very
vulnerable and sensitive person
also in some
ways that could be positive right so
i i guess that was always a fine line
wasn't it that we were trying to do
which was it wasn't like he switches to
some
real self or a fake self
it was more that
his connections are a bit messed up the
way that he can leap between emotions
is makes sense to him
or or he's kind of a hostage to that so
yeah there was lots of that where mary
was like you know give me this version
or give me that version
and they all made sense i hope
i hope i think i think to be honest just
to step in and just say uh to charlie's
credit he was extremely generous and
available and open and offered us lots
of iterations because also i think when
you're trying to nuance a relationship
like this on screen and a character
um you are trying you're not sure in the
edit how that person will read because
there's points even in the script
development uh people would pose the
question of
is this is simon's behavior at this
point extreme enough do we need to see
more do we need to see less and i think
i was aware that um a little goes a long
way and we didn't want to do something
very caricatured and broad and therefore
we needed the nuanced versions we needed
the subtle versions it's it's more scary
like when we yeah there was this the
scene that we were just talking about
about the with the still and there was
times where
it was like
you were going you were doing so many
different versions and there was like
really scary versions and then there was
these i thought the subtler ones were
terrifying you know
it's all about weakness with him right
like it's all about weakness so
this whole relationship of control is
like based upon all these unspoken
things and there's so many great the way
that mary's put it together there's so
many especially towards the end when you
start to see all that crumble and you
realize it was all just like
paper thin right it was all just easily
not easily but it just falls away just
like that because
what seemed to be strength is actually
great weakness
just got the wrap-up sign i have to wind
down with you all soon and it's crushing
me right now and i wanted to come your
way because you are also an executive
producer on this film and i love love
love seeing actors with a big platform
get behind the lens and use that
influence to get a movie out there that
might not have a super huge audience
without you so when you're signing on
for a project what makes you determine
for yourself this project is better off
if i'm serving as an executive producer
or any producer capacity for that matter
in addition to being a star in the movie
um
oh that's a tricky question to answer
because i'm so
bossy that it's difficult for me to not
feel like i should be in charge of
everything all the time
um which has never gone wrong for me um
uh yeah i don't know i i feel like um
uh that is a hard question to answer i i
um
i feel like
uh you know there there have been things
actually where i signed on as a producer
and i there was a thing where i showed
up and i was like
they don't need me to be doing anything
like everybody's actually done their job
that's wonderful um but i i think the
thing that
made me want to be able to say that i
was you know a producer on a film or
whatever because i spent so many years
going like i really
think i'm just trying to help and i
really think that this would help and to
just be kind of allowed to have that
voice um is incredibly valuable so um i
think it's so rare that you show up and
feel like okay everybody's on top of
everything that um
i
it's almost like a like a little
security blanket to feel like okay i'm i
have permission to have a voice here i'm
not just the annoying actress going i
think we should maybe think about this
um i'm now the annoying producer doing
that too
it's important to use that kind of voice
and that kind of weight to support films
that matter and it seems like you're
very much doing that right now before i
let you go i need to ask about a
directorial debut which is like another
massive massive step behind the lens i
was reading uh i think it was something
that you said where like it just felt
right like this all came together when
it showed what what exactly does that
mean can you elaborate no it's really
like i i was saying mary last night like
i really am not into things about like
oh the universe put it in my at the
right time and it's meant to be but this
is one of those things that feels like
unbelievably meant to be um because it
like the project like looked like it was
going to fall apart and then suddenly i
was like and we were looking for another
director and i just got this upwelling
of like
oh no i would be horrified if anybody
did it but me like i wouldn't let
anybody do it but me it's my like i felt
so certain that it was mine and um and
i'd never heard that thing about um you
should feel like you have a secret about
it and i absolutely feel like i have a
secret about this script and um that's
like lovely and then there was like a
weird thing where this just the screen i
know i'm still yeah from from sam
hillary clinton from joe wright yeah
we're all studying it from joe right
yeah yeah um but um but then there's
like weird connections where i i'd been
like sort of corresponding with the
screenwriter for while i was attached as
an actor and a producer but then once i
came on as a director and like we
actually met in person he was like i
i should probably tell you like we're
from the same hometown
and um like i think my dad was like a
substitute teacher at his boys high
school
at one point like it's just weird
you know meant to be stuff even though i
don't believe in that as a principal i
mean i kind of believe in it it's meant
to be you all being here is meant to be
thank you so much for your time and
talking about your experience making
alice darling congratulations again to
everybody out there keep an eye out for
this movie and stay tuned we will have
more from the supper suite at tiff 2022